Off. Selon la légende, Galilée fut puni
par l’Église pour avoir défendu la raison
et l’évidence de l’héliocentrisme, par
opposition à l’enseignement catholique
qui, de façon irrationnelle, mettait la Terre
au centre du monde. Pour éviter le bûcher,
Galilée aurait reconnu s’être trompé,
mais aurait doucement murmuré : « Et pourtant,
elle tourne… »
Euh… Comment dire… C’est un peu vachement
plus compliqué que ça. En fait, ce que je
vous propose, c’est d’imaginer un débat
sain entre deux intellectuels de chaque camp,
à l’époque de Galilée, vers 1615. Ça
ne va pas être historiquement ultra-rigoureux.
Oui parce qu’entre autres, un italien avec
des yeux bridés, ça le fait pas !
Ce qui m’intéresse, ce n’est pas la vérité,
mais les arguments de chacun pour justifier
ce qu’il pense de l’organisation du cosmos.
Car au fond, c’est ça la science. Ce n’est
pas la vérité, mais la recherche d’une
vérité…
S : Alors comme ça, tu penses encore que
la Terre est au centre du monde ?
G : Oui. Mais pour être clair, ce n’est
pas en Aristote que je crois, mais en Ptolémée…
S : C’est qui Ptolémée ?
G : Ptolémée ? Ptolémée, c’est un mathématicien
du 2ème siècle après Jésus-Christ. Sa
grande oeuvre, c’est l’Almageste. Et depuis
1500 ans, c’est la référence incontestée.
L’Almageste a passé le test du temps avec
un succès rare. Les grecs, les arabes et
les indiens l’ont tous endossé. C’est
une théorie formidable.
S : C’est vrai…
G : Et comme le modèle géocentrique de Ptolémée
vieux de 1500 ans n’a toujours pas été
mis à défaut par l’observation, je ne
vois même pas pourquoi on lui fait un procès
!
S : Mais t’es sûr qu’il est si juste
que ça le modèle de Ptolémée ?
G : Ça fait 1500 ans qu’on le teste. Tu
connais Tycho Brahe ? C’était un maniaque
ce mec. Il a collecté une montagne d’observations,
il avait tout plein de data, ou de Big Data
comme il les appelait, et ses data collaient
vachement bien avec le modèle de Ptolémée.
S : Enfin, si je comprends bien, Tycho Brahe
proposait une alternative.
G : En effet, il proposa de dire que Vénus,
Mars et compagnies tournent autour du Soleil.
Mais pour Tycho Brahe, la Terre reste au centre
du monde, et c’est le Soleil qui tourne
autour de la Terre. Et donc, pour Tycho Brahe,
Vénus, Mars et compagnie tournent autour
du Soleil qui tourne autour de la Terre.
S : Tycho Brahe est mort avant de faire toutes
ses analyses. Mais il paraît qu’il avait
embauché un petit génie du Saint-Empire
pour l’aider dans ses calculs…
G : Ah ouais ? C’est qui ce petit génie
?
S : Johannes Kepler, je crois.
G : Connaît pas.
S : Oui moi non plus…
G : En attendant, rien ne contredit Ptolémée.
S : T’es vraiment fermé d’esprit en fait.
T’as une vieille théorie et tu veux pas
en démordre…
G : Tu sais, l’alternative, l’héliocentrisme,
c’est pas nouveau. Y a 2000 ans, y a des
grecs qui y ont pensé. Mais ça a pas pris.
S : Peut-être. Mais, enfin, l’avantage
du modèle héliocentrique de Copernic, c’est
qu’il est quand même vachement plus élégant.
G : Mouais. Bof.
S : Bah quand même ! Dans le modèle de Ptolémée,
tout tourne autour de la Terre selon des épicycles,
c’est-à-dire des cercles dans des cercles.
Bref, des trucs compliqués quoi !
G : Oui, et je sais pas si tu le sais, mais
le modèle de Copernic en a encore plus !
S : Ah ouais ?
G : On s’est bien rendu compte que les planètes
ne tournaient pas de manière parfaitement
circulaire et à vitesse constante autour
du Soleil. Pour expliquer cela, non seulement
Copernic a utilisé des épicycles, pour accélérer
ou ralentir les trajectoires quand il le faut,
mais il a même été contraint de supposer
que ces épicycles tournent autour d’un
point imaginaire qui n’est pas le Soleil
!
S : Sérieux ? Le modèle de Copernic n’est
pas héliocentrique.
G : Et non ! Dans le modèle de Copernic,
le Soleil n’est PAS le centre de l’univers.
Et il n’est vraiment pas simple, son modèle.
Son bouquin, c’est un énorme pavé. Ça
fait mal, hein ?
S : J’avoue…
G : Pire encore, dans le modèle de Copernic,
la Lune tourne autour de la Terre qui fait
déjà un épicycle autour du Soleil ! La
lune fait un épicycle de plus dans un épicycle.
Et le plus dégueux dans cette histoire, c’est
que la Lune est la seule planète à faire
ça. Ça c’est vachement pas élégant.
Pourquoi l’univers aurait-il cette seule
et unique exception ?
S : Toi, t’as pas entendu parler de la découverte
récente de Galilée ?
G : Euh… je vois pas de quoi tu parles…
S : Galilée a créé une lunette qui permet
de voir des objets super loin. Un téléscope,
comme il dit. C’est magique comme invention
! Et il a vu que Jupiter avait plusieurs petites
planètes autour d’elle, un peu comme des
Lunes de Jupiter !
G : J’avais surtout entendu qu’il avait
vu que Saturne avait des oreilles… Mais
j’avoue, là, tu marques un point. Surtout
si on arrive un jour à voir que Saturne aussi
a des Lunes aussi, ça rendrait le modèle
de Copernic vachement plus crédible.
S : T’es en train de basculer de camp ?
G : Non, mais faut pas déconner. La principale
raison pour laquelle je pense que la Terre
ne bouge pas, c’est parce que je vois qu’elle
ne bouge pas ! Je veux dire, toi, tu la sens
bouger, la Terre ?
S : Non.
G : Bah voilà.
S : Mais Galilée a aussi postulé le principe
de relativité.
G : C’est quoi ça ?
S : C’est une idée trop classe ! Le principe
de relativité, c’est dire que le mouvement
est comme rien. Si t’es dans la calle d’un
bateau qui avance tranquillement, en particulier,
imagine qu’il ne tangue pas et qu’il avance
à vitesse constante, alors tout ce qui passe
dans la cale du bateau est identique à ce
qu’il se passe ici à Terre. Les lois de
la physique sont les mêmes que l’on soit
en mouvement uniforme, ou au repos. En fait,
mieux que ça, il n’y a pas un « repos
» universel. Le fait de ne pas bouger n’est
que relatif au référentiel dans lequel on
réfléchit. Par rapport au bateau, le mec
dans la cale du bateau ne bouge pas. Mais
nous, à Terre, par rapport au bateau, on
bouge.
G : Et donc…
S : Et donc, si la Terre bouge par rapport
au Soleil, ça ne change rien au fait que
nous ne bougeons pas par rapport à la Terre.
Que la Terre bouge ou non, le principe de
relativité affirme que l’on ne sentira
pas la Terre bouger !
G : Hummm… Je ne suis pas sûr d’être
100% convaincu.
S : C’est parce que je t’explique ça
comme ça. C’est même un peu faux ce que
je dis. Pour être plus précis, il faudrait
que je te parle de mouvements rectilignes
uniformes et de forces centrifuges. Mais lis
Galilée. Ce qu’il dit a beaucoup de sens
!
G : Tu me perturbes. C’est vraiment intéressant
tout ça… La parallaxe stellaire ?
S : La quoi ?
G : La parallaxe stellaire. J’aurais dû
y penser plus tôt. C’était l’argument
clé d’Archimède pour défendre le géocentrisme.
S : Archimède ? Le grand savant grec ?
G : Oui. Le plus grand mathématicien de tous
les temps ! Pour le coup, Archimède, tout
ce qu’il dit vaut de l’or, l’argument
pour le géocentrisme qu’il donne est implacable
!
S : C’est quoi cet argument ?
G : Prends deux stylos, et aligne-les. Ferme
l’oeil gauche. Le stylo de derrière est
alors à droite du stylo de devant. Ferme
maintenant l’oeil droite. Le stylo de derrière
est maintenant à gauche du stylo de devant.
Et ça, c’est parce qu’on a regardé les
stylos avec deux angles de vue différents.
C’est ce que l’on appelle la parallaxe.
C’est ce qui nous permet de voir en 3D.
S : Pour l’instant, je te suis.
G : Mais si la Terre tourne autour du Soleil,
entre Mars et Septembre, on a deux angles
de vue différents sur les étoiles de l’univers.
On devrait donc les voir différemment.
S : Hummm… Et c’est pas le cas ?
G : Non. Archimède avait fait des calculs
et avaient montré qu’étant donnés ses
appareils de mesure, l’heliocentrisme ne
serait tenable que si ces étoiles se trouvent
plus de 1 000 fois plus loin que Saturne.
Un truc débile quoi !
S : Ouais ça, ça a pas de sens. L’univers
ne peut pas être si grand… Tu m’as convaincu…
Texte à l’écran uniquement :
Quelques années plus tard, Johannes Kepler,
acheva son analyse minutieuse de l’énorme
base de données que Tycho Brahe avait connecté.
Après 5 ans et des centaines de pages de
calculs, Kepler finit par rejeter tout épicycle,
qu’il remplaça (non sans peine) par des
ellipses. Kepler écrivit : « Si, chers lecteurs,
vous vous ennuyez à la lecture de ces calculs
fastidieux, ayez pitié en moi, qui les ai
répétés 17 fois. »
En un certain sens, le modèle de Kepler n’est
ni géocentrique, ni héliocentrique. Le Soleil
n’est qu’un foyer des trajectoires elliptiques
des planètes. Un foyer. Pas le centre. C’est
la première loi de Kepler. En outre, Kepler
déterminera la
vitesse des planètes par rapport au Soleil,
en fonction de leur position dans l’ellipse.
Ces vitesses sont déterminées par les seconde
et troisième lois de Kepler.
Ce ne sera finalement qu’avec les lois de
Newton que ce débat sur la place de la Terre
dans l’univers sera clos. Pour Newton, l’univers
n’a pas vraiment de centre. Toute position,
comme toute vitesse, est relative. Mais comme
les objets plus massifs ont plus d’inertie,
il est moins faux de dire que la Terre tourne
autour du Soleil. Même si du coup, il est
moins faux encore de dire que le Soleil tourne
autour de la galaxie…